من الجيد أن نراك قد تحدثت
عدة مرات مع نظرائك في
جنوب إفريقيا حيث أصبح omicron
هو البديل السائد في غضون أسبوعين فقط ،
ما الذي يخبرونك به عن
الانتشار وربما الأهم من ذلك مدى
خطورة الحالات هناك
بشكل جيد مع الأخير  إنهم لا
يعرفون ، ونحن حقًا على
اتصال دائم افتراضي معهم ، فلديهم
عدد من المرضى الذين
يتابعونهم في منشآتهم
الطبية وأكدوا لنا أنهم سيعرفون على
الأرجح في غضون أسبوع في الأسبوع
و  نصف ما إذا كنا
نتعامل مع شيء في معظم
الأحيان يكون أكثر حدة بنفس القدر أو
أقل شدة ، يمكن أن يكون أي منهما في
الوقت الحالي لا يبدو أن هناك
إشارة كبيرة على درجة عالية من
الخطورة ولكن  من السابق لأوانه إخبار جيك
أننا نحتاج حقًا إلى انتظار
تزويدنا بالمعلومات التي كانوا
متعاونين للغاية
ومتعاونين وشفافين معنا حول ما
يجري هناك.
قال بايدن اليوم إنه لا
يتوقع توسيع قيود السفر لدينا
على الرغم من أن ما يقرب من 20
دولة قد أكدت الآن حالات
لمتغير omicron الجديد بالنظر إلى ما
رأيناه مع هذا الفيروس ،
هل تتوقع المزيد من قيود السفر
إذا ثبت أن omicron أكثر
عدوى  وأكثر فتكًا ،
لا أعتقد ذلك جيك ، أعتقد أن ما تم
فعله بشأن القيود المفروضة من جنوب
إفريقيا والدول المجاورة كان
فقط لأنه عندما ظهرت المعلومات
حول التركيب الجزيئي لهذا الفيروس
مع كل الطفرات التي كانت
مصدر قلق
شعرنا  كنا بحاجة إلى القيام بشيء ما على
الفور ، ونأمل ألا تكون هذه القيود
طويلة جدًا
حتى نتعامل مع ما
يحدث ولكننا لا نتوقع أي قيود أخرى